and i think i think what bootstraps
helps you and and
and and demand from you is to be
really really focused about what you're
doing and what you're not doing because
you cannot just
try to do so many things simultaneously
you have to pick the most impactful
thing that will drive the revenue
because if you won't drive the revenue
you won't be able to hire more people
so it helps you to be really good on
taking decision
on what's going to make an impact or not
welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
i'm excited to share with you the story
of an amazing startup lucia that was
bootstrapped for four and a half years
in the b2b sales space meet yonitsuya
co-founder and ceo of lucha as lucio's
co-founder and ceo
yoni first developed lucia as a side
project during his first job as an ios
developer
after one year his pet project exploded
and he decided to turn his passion into
his profession
today he only helps create the vision
and strategy that informs all products
and business decisions at lucia
he focuses on hiring the right team
anticipating the future needs of
customers
and envisioning the future of the data
world as software engineer by trade he
only graduated with the bsc from ben
gurion university
yonitsu welcome to 20 minute leaders
from the lucia offices i'm assuming
welcome
thank you thanks for inviting me how are
you i am doing great good morning to
both of us
uh yoni you're stationed in the middle
of one of the most fascinating
fascinating industries and that that are
new
you know they these one of the few one
of the industries that just didn't exist
you know if just a few years ago at
least not in the scale
and the complexity that we're seeing
today in a data-driven world and we're
talking about
b2b sales and we're talking about
understanding how do we reach
the relevant people with the relevant
content in a globalized world
and and i'm really excited to dive deep
both into lucia but also dive deep into
your life yoni and how
and what led you to understand the
market the way that you did and a
personal conviction of what's happening
so yoni who who are you
who is yoni okay so so let me start a
bit because you have several questions
uh so i'm yoni i'm 36 years old
i'm father of three um i founded the
lucha with uh with my partner asap five
years ago
um and when we when we found lucia
we basically try to solve a problem for
recruiters
when they need to reach out to potential
candidates and
and it's really hard for them to do it
over the web and over uh social networks
uh so uh we knew my partner knew the
pain of the recruiters really really
well and we started to solve that
and give them the ability to and
business contact details and easily
uh reach out to potential candidates but
very quickly we understood that
the real big pain in the world and and
and the real customer of lucia is the
salesperson
uh because very quickly they discover
the product and their potential with it
so
since then uh most of our focus is on
providing the best
data and insight for sales people to to
make the world
work much more productive i i have to
delay on on
this exact you you said it in two
sentences but it feels to me like this
was
you know a big big milestone for the
company you're starting off with
recruiters
and then somehow it gets picked up by
salespeople and you
understand that actually your your real
product market fit
is in the latter type of people right
yeah i think uh i mean
we we we realized that recruiters
recruiters and sales are similar in a
way
they're the main the main difference is
that recruiters are very picky
with the people they really want to
connect with and salesperson
or less so they need more data than than
recruiters and
but actually they both of them need to
reach out and and just you know
create a deal uh so we just
we saw that there are many more sales
people in the world and the need
and the understanding and their and the
willingness to buy
technologies is just more advanced and
and and this problem is just much bigger
because
sales methodology today is still
spray and pray if you think about it you
have a lot of sales people
they just try to reach out and connect
with no
not enough data for company try to buy
and i think that the world is
transforming into
selling uh with much more data so you
are much more
focused and you have a spotlight on the
right company where the
when the potential is the highest and i
think there are several trends in the
world today that we see
that you know the the fastest gross
growth growing company today are
providing self-service business
in addition to traditional sales and and
what's happened is that
and even if you have traditional sales
you today you can sell to anyone in the
world
and it's become really easy and the
challenge is that
your customer base increased
dramatically and the sales
teams just cannot offer human touch to
every potential buyer
or every user in the system so what they
need to have is they need to have
accurate data so they will know where to
focus and where and where their
real potential is and and to emphasize
that the best companies today even if
they provide self-service model
still 10 of their customers represent 70
of the sales of the revenue the
challenge is how do you identify and
distinguish
who are those 10 that you need to focus
your sales efforts in
and just don't waste your time on the
small or low potential buyers
and so this is what you try to provide
them in the best way
so if i understand correctly you're
taking this idea that
you know just statistically speaking ten
percent of the customers of
most companies are indicative of seventy
percent of the revenues and therefore
if we're looking at the human to human
sales cycle
those are where we should be optimizing
even if we do have a self-service
you know a method of onboarding this is
where we want to prioritize and that is
exactly
where lucia interjects right exactly and
and let me give you some examples um of
how
different the story of a company can be
because i can give you two companies
with 200 employees for example
but one company last year they were 100
employees and they just raised money and
you know they are growing really really
fast so that that's company that's
growth fast and you probably can sell
them much easily
then if you're gonna have a 200 company
which you know last year they were 300
people
and they're shrinking or they are not
growing or you know it's a different
story
so the main challenge today i think we
sell teams is that they still work
on a very shallow data
which doesn't tell you any story it's
just really static data and this is the
way they filter their audience so they
get tons of potential buyers
and it's not right because you actually
have a really
it's if you really get deeper into the
company story
there is a different trend there is a
different um
timing that you need to reach out to
every company to to make the sale
and if you are able to provide them the
best
and the highest potential companies to
focus on at the right time
they will be much more effective and and
it's a trend that
the cells is transforming more and more
into
into science and into data-driven
mode you know one of the things that as
as i'm listening to i'm contemplating
it's
you know i you know i find that in a lot
of the transitions it going
goes back to linear algebra and this
idea that you know if before
sales was really two-dimensional you
have you know who is the right client
for me and how do i approach them but
you're actually saying well today we're
adding a few more layers of complexity
such as what is the right time to
approach them and these are all really
data-driven questions that you know if
you could potentially answer them with
with analysts but you could never
possibly scale
to attempt to cover you know even five
percent of your potential market right
and and having a technology that does
that on scale and
generalized for companies makes a lot of
sense
yeah and and and there are a lot of
companies there is specific time where
they need to reach out let me give you a
simple example lucia just raised money
uh several months ago and we just built
a new finance team
and the probability that the company
like us with those criterias
now need to integrate erp system is
really really high
and once we will integrate erp system we
probably won't change it for the next
five six years
and and so you need to identify all the
companies that are currently building a
finance team
and they need to integrate erp otherwise
you're going to lose this momentum and
this
you have you have a specific time window
that you need to reach out to
so that's a simple example which an erp
company we
will need to target their their
potential buyers but there are tons of
that you know
every company targets different
time frame in the company life cycle i i
love that example because i think it
just illustrates
you know that at the end it's nothing
about not even about your
your own product it has something to do
with a company somewhere in the world
that happens to be in a window of
opportunity where maybe there was just a
press release or the data was just
released and what i'm hearing is
you know in the next three weeks or so
they're going to be bombarded with
you know different erps and they're
going to make a decision so this is the
window of opportunity for the decision
now yoni as your as you're learning
about sales and as you're learning about
b2b and
and you know what works and what doesn't
work we're in 2021 what what can i
learn from your now five years of
experience in the field
as i go on my journey with sales what
are some things that you learned
i think there is a lot of way to to to
answer this question i think that
um traditional sales as i said are
moving
from you know like really high volume
sales or spray and prey
into super targeted prospecting so if
you know your customers
you need to be very very accurate about
who you need to reach out to
and they need to put more efforts on
lower amount of leads
that's the classic sales but in general
when i think about sales
i think that the world is changing in a
way that
you know today 75 of the people
expect to self-educate themselves before
they talk to sales rep or before they
buy and and this is by salesforce data
by the way
and and why is that it i think because
we are all consumers and as a as a
consumer when you buy a shirt when you
buy sunglasses when you buy iphone when
you buy a car you try before you buy it
right
you you drive you wear you you give it
you try
you just don't want to buy it and it's
there is no difference when when you
when you try to buy software you just
want to try so
more and more companies today are
providing self-service
experience in it and and only then
when you know the product when you saw
that it works for you and even if
after you put credit card inside the
only then you can reach out to sales
when you need to scale and you or when
you have specific questions
and i think that the motion of sales is
transforming that instead of talking to
prospects
and people that doesn't know anything
about you then
the world is moving into talking to
users
and people that already know a lot of
information about your product but
your job is to connect the dots and make
sure that you you make them successful
so so if you think about it sales today
is becoming
more and more like product experts and
and help you
succeed rather than uh rather than just
you know
tap on the play and pitch you the 30
minutes 30 seconds page
yoni take me back five years please the
founding of lucha
i'd love to hear the lucious story and
and it starts with
the name because that's just amazing
yeah so so the name was uh was the idea
of my
my partner staff um lucia was the was
the nickname of his daughter
so several years ago i think eight years
ago or something he bought this domain
and
he said to himself one day i'm gonna do
something with it and then when we met
um i mean basically when i met him he
just wanted to buy data from me i had
data and he
had another startup and he just wanted
data but he told me hey you know you can
do this in this product
just in reach over the web and and each
one of us like
went home and thought about it and after
two weeks we spoke
and then i told him you know i never
spoke i never stopped thinking about
this idea and he said yeah
i didn't stop thinking about it as well
and then we said okay let's do it
together
and so we launched the company and we
did it really really fast after two
months we already have
product out there really slow and clunky
but two months
and i think that's the story of lucia i
think since since we simply launched the
company
we ran really really fast with small
iterations
and we did it bootstrap for four and a
half years so
the first four and a half years we grew
to 12 000 customers
um with no funding just because we built
something really really simple and and
and really fast
um and so everything i think in the
journey was just
you know you learn from bottom up it was
bottom-up experience we we didn't know
at the beginning
you know we're gonna be that big or
we're gonna do that we just
we started and along the way we just
discovered more and more opportunities
and more and more
things that we need to improve and and
up until today
it's so it's all it also happens today
as you're running bootstrap
for for four and a half years as a
leader of the company you know you can't
necessarily afford some of the luxuries
that a vc backed company
with all the downsides of dilution and
more partners and more complexity
that has decided but but it but it also
it is an enabler
for for growth for you know nice offices
for good salaries
how do how do you deal with that as a
ceo with the fact that that you don't
have this extra
five million dollars in the bank after
six months
to to just go nuts what does that do to
you i think that
yeah i think i think we that we did we
did
build uh great offices and we paid
competitive salaries and we did
everything like that but we
we just did very small stuff really
really well
so we we put uh we
gave good salaries to people and when we
built great offices but we didn't do any
marketing for example
and we and we didn't have another site
and
but what we did we did really really
lean
and i think i think what bootstraps
helps you and
and and and demand from you is to be
really really focused about what you're
doing and what you're not doing because
you cannot just
try to do so many things simultaneously
you have to pick
the most impactful thing that will drive
the revenue because if you won't drive
the revenue you won't be able to hire
more people
so it helps you to be really good on
taking decision
on what's going to make an impact or not
and i think this is a muscle that
that was very important for us it's it's
i call it a revenue muscle you learn how
to create revenue and sometimes
not necessarily but sometimes in
companies that you know are vc-backed
they just are they're not sensitive
enough for for revenue growth because
they just
raise more money and it will come along
the way some way someday but it's
actually something that you need to
build
capabilities for and and and i think
this is something that's going to be
part of our dna for forever
i love that you're taking the discussion
to focus driven because
you know one of the aspects that i i
haven't given much thought to is this
idea that
you know with the luxury of raising
money and having that stability
all of a sudden you might find yourself
you know being tempted to try a bunch of
different things bring more r d
to things that you didn't don't
necessarily believe in and
even if those are great experiments to
run your
focus as a core team especially in the
early stages
you know starts getting divided and the
the critical things become blurred with
the
nice to have things and then you lose
focus and what i'm hearing from you yoni
is that you forced yourself on the team
to remain dead focused
on really the on target things that
you're being measured on
and then four and a half years later
what happens
and then we realize that the opportunity
is really really high
and and we that we have the passion to
build a big company and
and and we need more resources to do
that so once we were
committed for the big dream for the
really big dream and and we
we knew that we want to make this
journey then we we just added a
financial partner because
you cannot run that fast without
resources
and uh we understood that we need to do
more stuff simultaneously we're still
we're still focused company if you think
about it but we just do
a bit more stuff and we we run faster
and one of the main things that we added
recently
is actually marketing efforts which
which really helped us to grow
so i think that that was the main main
additional thing that we've done since
the funding
i'll just point out the irony that a
sales b2b
company didn't do much marketing for the
first four and a half years
of its life cycle i think that's pretty
cool i have to say
yeah i think i think though i think it
was
because we we actually didn't raise uh
but
but but actually it the real the real uh
the real reason for that is because
we're a product led company and we built
the product so
in a traditional company marketing bring
leads to sales
and sales and cover the product to the
customer right
it's like it's marketing sales and
product is less in a product led company
and a self-serve
company it's it's a bit different it's
marketing bring leads to the product
and then you can try you can buy you can
use and if you need scale you go to
sales
so sales is is is the last in the funnel
and it
speak to users as we said but it changed
it changed
then the need for but that's a huge
market because if the product really
really works well
people will come and and this is what
happened to us
all right no i love this yoni the story
is amazing
i i love what you guys are doing and and
i encourage everybody to go check out
and the web it's beautiful what do you
what you've done there
um it feels like i'm almost in a like in
a luna park
when i go to the website and it just
feels good
and and i love what you guys are doing
and i love the story and and
the journey which is you know a lot of
people say the journey is more important
than the end here i think i i'm learning
so much from
from observing the journey and i think
that there's a lot of really important
lessons on
humbleness and prioritization and focus
to be learned from
from from the story of lucha and i and
i'm and i'm sure that it will be told
a lot more uh you know in the in the
coming years and so thank you for taking
the time to be here
i have a few questions about yoni not
about yeah
going back to middle school and high
school what was your favorite subject
um first honestly i didn't like uh
learning in school nobody still likes
learning in middle school in high school
it's crazy
yeah i mean because because the way you
learn is like
memorize the material and and i always
thought that i don't like to learn back
then
today i i knew that i learned that i
really really like to learn
because i have passion to do it uh but
back then the two subjects that i really
focused on
was math and physics my father is a
physics professor so i couldn't let down
on
uh on this subject but those were the
two i
honestly the rest of the subject i was
an average
you know student and and um just did
what i had to do to pass
everything uh but those are the ones
that i put more efforts in
wow who would be a role model of yours
somebody that inspires you
uh i think uh i think brian elligan
the co-founder and ceo of hubspot um
and i'll tell you why i think first i
think he built an amazing company with a
real story
and and and and uh and thought
leadership attitude
um and i really like everything they did
there in terms of product and and
and stuff but i think what i really like
about him
is that he looks like he's the journey
enjoying the journey
and he doesn't take himself too
seriously and and he just had fun
and and i think the combination between
both
is just inspiring in my opinion be so
successful and
and just enjoy what you do in in such an
you know
honest way so i really like him and the
way dude
amazing and what are three words that
you
would use to describe yourself
um i think dynamic
really really move fast once i
understand something i think
intuitive i use my gut feel a lot
uh and i learn to use it more and more
as as i grow
and i hope the third one will be easy
going uh because this is where i try and
try to do it as much as i can yoni
i love it thank you okay this episode it
was great
and and i can't wait to continue
following lucia today stay safe
[Music]